last five starts do you realize he has
not given up a home run he's only walked
three batters in 27 innings pitched only
seven hits and 43 strikeouts that's just
in his last five starts but double
herrera leads off for the phillies and
degrom's first fastball is popped up
alonso should have a play in foul ground
one pitch and one retire
[Applause]
and that's driven to deep left field
back goes smith he's there to make the
catch a bullet off the bat of hoskins
one two coming and harper goes down on
strikes
and degrom has yet another one two three
opening inning his 12th in a row
now there's big zach his 15th start he's
two at six an era of 4.39
but yes i was surprised by that
a little looper out towards center field
oh double got a really good jump but
he's there
swinging a miss went upstairs to get a
strikeout his first of the day
nickordos hit by a pitch so he's a boy
with two outs
bouncer over the left side williams goes
the short way to second and the inning
is over
mccutchen lines one off to grom and past
peraza and into center field
[Applause]
there goes mccutchen
pitches the strike throw to second base
on one hop goes into center field it'll
be a stolen base
one ball no strikes to maitan and nick
lines it out toward right field that's
going to be in for a base hit
mccutchen's around third heading for
home it's just the third base hit this
year against degrom with the rudder in
scoring position
and the phillies take a one-nothing lead
jacob degrom's scoreless streak ends at
31 innings
that's it sharply but right at lindor
and the underhand flip to peraza for the
force that ends the inning but the
phillies scratch a run against degrom
and lead it one nothing in the second
dom was one for seven in the
doubleheader yesterday
and he lines one toward the middle base
hank
taking advantage of ronald torres being
only five foot six
mcken bloops one shallow right harper
coming on
and he gets it on a hop
no they call it a catch no he didn't he
didn't catch it the first base on park
called it a catch but there's no way he
caught that ball he trapped it first
base umpire ryan attitude was close now
he goes safe
and he lines one down the left field
line for a base hit
dom smith will score mccann racing for
third he'll be held up there as his dug
out of the corner by mccutcheon jose
perazo
under the weather yesterday on top of
the world today rbi double the tie the
game at one
and jake grounds one down to first
hoskins is going to come home with it
and he's out he didn't i don't know
about that i don't know if his foot hit
the bag he hit hit the plate
i think to get a little bit of the foot
in the way and he gets up in the air
[Music]
yeah he's out you're right he never
touched home plate
out toward left not deep mccutchen's
there
makes the catch what a job really good
job well done zach
one two coming
struck him out got him with a slider
third strikeout for the ground
back toward the middle
hit the bag and it does hit the bag and
it then chops up on lindor
on the ground he's short so harper will
have to hold
and lindora throws out wayne luto for
the first out one two coming to
mccutcheon
and he pops it up shallow right
conforto looking through the sunglasses
and puts it away for the second out
three two coming struck in half
the grom strands harper by striking out
williams his fourth strike out of the
day
and he strikes out maintain on three
sliders yep five strikeouts now for
degrom
for two straight games but he fixed it
effluent grounds one is short lindor
slides over to his left and it's a one
two three and against the bottom third
of the order
took him just six pitches to get through
halfway 1-1
0-2 pitch swinging to miss
the second time he's coming out more and
that is nasty he cannot figure out that
sinker westerns they were in western
get-up when he heard this the drama up
the middle he's got himself another hit
12th hit of the year for jacob degrom
for two he's struck out in flight out
and he pops it up oh this has been a
heck of a five innings
for zach eflin
oh dubois whacks that one down the right
field live that's a fair ball that ends
in 0-4 oh double and he's gonna pull on
the second base with a stand-up double
[Applause]
outside ball four reese works out a walk
and the phillies have two on with nobody
out here in the sixth inning
he does show button and hits him on one
hop herrera goes over to third he'll be
there anyway
that's going to leave a heck of a mark
by tomorrow
isn't it yes it will
1-2
popped it up not very deep
now mora under it tagging herrera and
he's not gonna try it
now more with a one-hop strike to the
plate and that's the first down
and the 1-1
that one's out towards center field
almora is there makes the catch herrera
tanks from third he's coming home the
throw to the plate is not in time it
gets by mccann
the run scores on a sac fly by andrew
mccutchen it's a 2-1 phillies lead
3-2 coming
right back to degrad
side retire
and the curve ball misses for ball four
a rare walk for athlete
and james
chops one toward third tough play
williams the glove and the throw and it
gets away from hoskins racing for third
is conforto he'll be held up there and
into second base goes mccann
[Applause]
bouncer over to third flag down by
williams little spin will throw in time
and the inning is over
in the previous year with toronto
but last year with tampa he figured
something out as torayas figures
something out there with a base hit to
left
[Applause]
and he bunts at it and it's a fair ball
it turns out to be a nice bunt beauty
and he hits one down to third a squirmer
grabbed by guillermo and he throws him
out that ball had a lot of spin on it
now it'll be kevin pilar to pinch it for
aaron luke
and he drives this one out to right
field chasing jankowski back to the
warning track at the walls are here
kevin
ties the game with an officer field home
run
he said he had been working on driving
the ball the other way and he does it
again he sure does
oh well touching his drill
that fastball can get away from edwin
every now and again
catch goes pitch is taken low for or
lost in the strike zone and mccutcheon
is safe at second that's his second
stolen base
and that one gets away goes all the way
back to the wall mccutcheon goes to
third
williams is aboard
[Applause]
that one's looped out toward left going
back on it as smith tagging at third as
mccutchen here he comes
and the throw is cut off it's a sac fly
for maton
it's his second rbi of the day
here's the reyes and there goes the
runner from second the throw by mccann
and he's safe wow williams steals third
he beat it oh he hit the shoe though
he's out how about that that's a great
shot it's just a terrible slide and a
good foot by guillermo getting it in the
way and they're going to overturn this
one two coming and he's struck him out
so diaz pushed the inning to bed but the
philly's gonna run without a hit in the
bottom of the ninth and blankenhorn
pulls one down at first knocked down by
hoskins can he find it he can't and
blankenhorn is safe
3-2 coming
now mckinney takes high and it gets away
from rail muto but blankenhorn will
merely go to second
and pilar hits what toward the whole
correas knocks it down and that'll load
the bases
three two coming
full four the game is
tied and now the 1-2 pitch
swing and a miss he got him with a split
one out
one-two coming to conforto
and he lines one to center field herrera
makes the catch here comes mckinney here
comes the throw by herrera save for the
mets winner
michael conforto with the walk-off
sacrifice fly as the mets rally for two
in the bottom of the ninth and beat the
phillies four to three